in remembers wind Republic
this happened to all myself
I thought reason the emergency
evacuation announcement of in the event
of fire or other emergency please exit
the building in an orderly manner
incentive points located to market car
park authority in this room is indicated
by green fire exercise please do not
delay the declaration must elect in the
kingdom do not use the lift primitive
must not be really intended for the
Barbican of giving the all clear things
out against the laws of smoke London
princes and he's also hope that this
meeting will be wanted a recorded in
pockemon one turn off or turn them off
thanks to solving and agenda item number
one team in Polish practice you have the
same voltage we capsule appoint as
inspired Kepler is sure and cancer
Newport substitute or cancer for give
complementing substitute for cancer Shaw
as a council Lucasfilm and substitute
for council our new bodies counselor
the non-member tending their on agenda
item [ __ ] are meeting to meeting to
achieve their taking counselor miss
Mayton
all members have received 2
communications from Merman the public
indicating that we maids on the 1st of
June or incorrect and serve all members
of the wrong number of those people
seeking shelter combination one buys
them cents 41 you should say 7 to 5
I think she would think director will
clarify minds or some impressions 41 in
Riley precedent specifics life telling
I've devoted my recollection Devon was
even the number 75 was was also given
otherwise I would have known if our next
mission and attract things share one
small point and be respect of the
minutes of the meeting on the 13th of
June
you'll recall that scientist
vice-chairman which is indicated in
there and it's no wonder those
particularly relevant the everything we
can imagine to show that make the first
two days to Clara science to seventy
five and forty words to look for them
projects we're giving us some my
husband's relations that has given the
substance of amazing it's important that
there is a reason given at the wine I
would legally required to be substituted
for that meeting and millions of a group
setting
I don't have be illegal to actually
formulate a full of words that are
appropriate that indicate why I should
be substituting any other comments on an
item started operations of events
generally undesirable vehicle mine
through bringing rotten tree resins
member - okay
and moving on to item six - the treasury
management and your view everybody sure
whether in fact available emails even
which on college you'll automatically
different or financial salim and math
tax afters that well has been just a
crudely variables i like in any point of
view bills absolutely yep
thank you Jim and and the report is
basically an overview of 2016 17
financial year in terms of treasury
management and how our authority has
done with the cash that we've had put
out on deposit with various institution
and I guess the highlight of the report
if you can call it a highlight I'm
pleased to say that we achieved better
return on investments than we budgeted
so the revised budget was thirty
thousand pounds and we achieved thirty
five thousand nine hundred and eighty
five so for an authority that is putting
these funds mainly one hundred percent
currently in thanks Iran society the
money market funds that represents a
fairly good return for our size of
authority I guess I just want to point
out a couple of other things as well and
previously I came to to this committee
and met with counselor mr. and mrs.
Mason regarding options around treasury
management advisors the report states we
are coming to the end of our contracts
with capita asset services formerly
known as sex or Treasury services they
are our advisors and basically supplied
information on credit ratings market
watches interest rate forecasts
including interest rates from borings as
well provide training sessions and such
and we explored various options around
whether we could look to the County
Council for that expertise given that
this Authority procures it's one five
one from Essex County Council and having
spoken to the section one five one
officer whilst a lot of that information
could be provided by county it doesn't
necessarily come within the limitations
of the contract that we have with them
for the role of section one Wi-Fi off
sites so potential there that we have to
pay extra for additional costs that
addition of services so his advice is
that we go out to tend that while
leading up to this to the new year to
really let this service for another
period of time just want to highlight
one one other thing that probably stands
out a bit and that's under investment
position item four on page six point
three you'll notice there that the
investment position has gone from zero
to five million pounds within the year
and just just really put some
explanation on that it wasn't that we
didn't have any money at the end of 2016
it was just that we didn't have anything
out on investment what funds we did have
was just sitting in our current account
at the end of 2016
whereas at the financial year we've just
closed we actually had five million
pound out on investment with various
institutions I don't think there's
anything else I particularly want to
emphasize it I think one life point
actually I mean just to emphasize that
the budget that was that was based
around base rate either Spain where it
is or possibly rising in there whereas
in fact it is real moment did drop two
point two five percent yes so just want
to highlight that thirty five thousand
is a good return given base rate dropped
during the
I'm happy to take any questions okay
thank you very much
come to me chairman I'd like to follow
up on the matters raised with the
recommendation on behalf of the project
team I would just mention as the project
team it sounds like it was very
restricted it was I was only checking
members because that happened that
councilman is most online with the ones
present nevertheless the matters before
this committee today so if there are any
matters that need to be raised and
additionally they can be a nod to ask
the question of the officer about
procurement in particular the project
team has advised that Barclays Bank PLC
or the possibility clearly there are
others
does the officer have at this stage an
idea of what organizations will be
invited to submit effectively offers and
tenders for this contract will it
include Barbic bankers and this stage I
don't have a definitive list of who will
be invited and given that the one-five
line officer has now said that ethics
won't be providing those services we
will look now to be starting that
processes with as we build up to January
next year in the after the summer recess
so September time onwards so we can look
to build build a list of possibilities
as far as I'm aware there are only two
organizations that are like capita who
provide the whole package as it were and
that's that's capita and are in close
another company in the market having
said that I believe caps are in the
capital Treasury services are in the
process of being bought out so that
might open up further possibilities over
the coming months but now we will be
looking at every opportunity to bring in
as much competition as
into the tender prices production mmm
thank you obviously this is got your
program read the Kerman if this
recommendation is followed I see no
reason why it shouldn't but it may I ask
where a member oversight is going to be
provided in relation to the tender
process and the tender appointment and
just try to think when as we bring three
treasury management reports into you
year for the next one won't be until the
treasury management strategy statement
which would be in January so we would
have to bring in a separate report as
part of the budget process during
September October
so generally do I conclude as the
recommendation should also include a
reference to the faculties will return
to the review committee
what can I just fit in we've got the
media review then the 5th December ah
yes we do correct we could bring it in
then would that be to class or nah well
we wouldn't know that should be fine and
it's not going to be a long tender
process much before the commenced part
in February we are advised to give
Amundson answers yeah in January yeah so
at the end of February sighs yeah though
because January we will be giving exists
a set of December would be fine for
physics and what you can do is have
people see that as as I thinking
presumably for the tender process we'll
be drawing up some sort of specification
is that is the intention for that to
come back to us as well
and that specification that we use last
time was basically a list of the
services that we required as a finance
function here at Rochford having said
that the services we get are no
different the services that you would
get if you of any local authority and
that kappa to provide their service
- but again I can bring that back in to
the same meeting on how to do that in
Athens
yeah that would have to be needed prior
to the process of commencement when when
do you intend for the opportunity
process it will be after Christmas so
5th December will be fine right good
I'll make the suggestion you could use
the same house and finish grade yep -
yogurt respect and what's required
beforehand yep and then go into this
standard 97 if members are how to you
know have a meeting in November yeah
calculus
thank you mr. jereth is a local fairly
poor I think that would be advisable
especially as some of the items that we
had were receiving in a report when we
questioned the validity so that the
Suffolk see much point in going out and
tender on something if we can don't need
the whole package we need to look at the
package that we require rather than the
package that we have I think that was
discussed at Sunday enforcement being
lovely automation is duplicated so I
would certainly suggest that the obvious
is proposal that we meet in November at
the same and Torian are talking finish
group which would then put so forth
process onto that decision that can then
come back to fall will be on 5th
December Thank You German and I get an
impression that we are looking for the
same informations other local
authorities and we basically procure the
basic package some local authorities
might have a larger portfolio where they
their requirements are in more detail
for example we are currently debt-free
doesn't mean that we might not be there
for you next year when we procure but
currently we're debt-free so there are
there is advice given on how to manage
your debt portfolio and things like that
at the moment we have the basic package
that capital would offer an authority of
our size and if we need to buy extra
services in we just purchased them as
and when we need them having said that I
don't think we have this year that we
haven't so is there a possibility that
if we're looking for some things that
other Authority we could share and
reduce cost
I don't think capital would go down that
route their whole purpose in life is to
make money a security office and I think
their argument would be the output value
is different to any other councils and
it's they may tailor their reports to
our specific requirements you take a
chair with some as you remember last
time we met I believe I did show some
interest in other councils where their
product is earning more than what we are
have we looked into that and
it implies to what we can actually do
because there was nothing in there's
nothing in here that says you know yeah
we have so so basically the return
management strategy that was agreed for
2016
back in January 2016 and took by
specially members wanted to mitigate
risk so it was decided to continue with
the structure that we only invest in
safe banks building societies money
market funds we did and at the time the
section one five one officer did bring
to this to this committee options around
investing in property funds and such but
it was felt that we wanted to mitigate
those risks as we were still achieving a
fairly healthy return for for the
investments we that we were able to
place having said that the treasure and
strategy for next year will be brought
back in to January's review committee
and those options can be looked at again
we'll come back eleven random faces I
know we was looking at I plus plus or
whatever it was that we were looking at
and and we all don't believe it was
brought to our attention that perhaps we
could look at the I plus R and then the
double heavy definitely that one's
looking
and they it seems that others may have
got a little bit better financial
compared with them from what we have I
know we've done well in comparison to
what the going rate is yeah at two point
point two five but obviously there's
other areas where we could probably look
at to looking forward a little bit more
than that I mean together for that makes
you here to come involved for company so
we we are we are doing the best we can
expectedly the list of a length on with
we're not at the risk you're always say
well you don't want the risk but other
thing to absorb even if members decide
to go down the route of investing
propped in property funds or
institutions of investment opportunities
like that then potentially the return
could be three four percent and
having said that members of this
authority decided that we wanted to
maintain our portfolio with the
institution's we use and that portfolio
would be no different to any other of
both you know that we are getting the
best rates we can with the options we
have so for example I met with Santana
Santander bank today and they're in the
throes of launching a six-month fixed
term investment account that will pay
your 0.7%
now that's pretty good in today's market
and we will be looking to put some money
into that but that's the top end of what
we're getting at the moment for a fixed
rate investment as a save if we had gone
down the property fund route then
potentially three four percent would but
they aren't there there is risk attached
to that thank you so we could say we
could get because Chris name is fast a
risk assessment for that at the time
because obviously this changes with me
so we have a risk assessment validity
yeah absolutely and that is that is part
of the service I believe ethics would be
able to get involved in and I believe
they did when that was brought in
originally last year and the chief
accountant and Essex who is also the
treasury management chief of sub relief
attended this committee and presented
with with your section offer once along
with many reference if you calculate
according and you know there's been
speculation about interest rates
more in the upward direction when this
is being looked at against of January
next year we could be in a position
where interest rates a comment and and
you have you taken that into
consideration in sort of not some of
your calculations where you thinking
okay well we haven't started to think
about the 1919 budget yet but we will be
in September October and that will be
very much at the forefront of our
thinking and and that is one of the
areas that we'll be working with capita
they basically every month have a
interest rate subgroup that meet within
their organization and it follows on
from the bank of in your meeting
basically and I think the last Bank of
India meeting as you say was quite
closely it had been in quite a while
five three other leaving three people
voting for Ray Rice
having said that base rate going up
doesn't necessarily mean that interest
rates in banks building societies will
go up their rates depend on in the bank
boring morons and how their balance
sheet is looking to be honest but it
might mean Rachael Villa but it'd be
something yet we tend to leave the
treasury management interactive interest
budget up until the very last moment so
we are basically setting the budget on
the very last bit of information we have
before we come to full council in
January but to be honest you know even
if place rate might go up quarter one
percent maybe half a percent from what
I'm being told from capita it's very
unlikely to go above from your point
seven five percent within that financial
year so yeah we're still only talking
maybe thirty thousand now these or why I
know that it sounds a bit flippant but
considering where we were at 1012 years
ago when we were generating eight nine
hundred thousand pound from trophy
management investments these it's still
it's not going to bridge a gap put it
that way
do well Thank You councillor spamming
slavery chairman Kuk done I wonder if
you could give us some sort of idea and
additional coming to the end of
financial year if you like but how other
councils and especially those that have
seemed to have done better than us if
you could give us some indication and
we're in this in a document of something
that can show you know should we have
made that lien where would we be now in
fact not when I spoke last on I think we
should have done but you know and it
seems to completely dollars right but
I'd like to know where the others were
in relation to us so I wonder if that
could be brought forward later in the
end I'm not sure if I'm going to be able
to get that kind of information out and
not exactly out of them but I mean all
you must know what's going to be in the
market you must know what's what others
liability I'm assuming so there's only
two sources that you were going to say
that from bond lien captor fear of
attacks I mean they wouldn't give you
the information that I'm asking to
repeat your sources and so yeah they
were laughing yeah I mean what they
would publish is there so for example we
publish the 35,000 as our investment in
years but that doesn't show how we got
there they would show how much they
generated but I'd have to go to each of
my counterparts that the other districts
to say are you happy for me to share
that information with our members can we
also I can ask you I'm going to make you
some say no comment
bemis I would add to that like the the
options that were laid before you five
one five one were it were the options
that are there now so and they're only
going to tell me what this lays before
you of other things that we didn't go
for I have a couple of questions one was
think mark put you on the spot but
someone it's in the report here that the
capital contract cost six thousand pound
per year in the advice service freed up
up at a time when we said in the money
market to move the investment decisions
inmate economy passion is it your engine
that six thousand pound a year is
batting for money yes it is okay thank
you my second question with regard to
the addendum that we've had and it says
edit it would be expected the cafetaria
tech services wouldn't be tender for the
business if this happens I have an
antenna and beam dependency me that
there are we only two companies that are
involved in that sort of I services and
the capital and talent has has been
purchased you know who purchase by and
whether the new purchasers is been
involved in that or could we potentially
find ourselves with literally one
alternative option
now what I've been told from our
relationship manager is that we will see
no difference so the company that are
taking them over will continue to as far
as who's aware and his position will
continue to provide the services that we
currently get that doesn't mean though
that when we go out to tender that they
might suddenly hike their prices up or
offer a totally different package or
might not even want to deal with
accounts of our size I don't know but
where they haven't suggested it's not
that I you know if anything they're
having to to continue
Oh counselor mrs. Martin Thank You mr.
Chen I think one of the things that we
still haven't investigated and which
will put a different aspect on this is
the impossibility of using banks who
also we know from personal experience
that they have this information behind
they provide it for their own investors
and there's no reason why they couldn't
perhaps in fact provide it for Elektra
District Council and that still is
waiting for their principal financial
officer to explore so when we have the
meeting there then hopefully that
information will be available and that
will put some more clarity on that
as regards the speculation over interest
rates I think some of the members here
weren't around when that report was
given by the the options were given one
section one five one officer which was a
very thorough and very well debated
documents and at the time the property
management of risk was perceived as very
high because the inquisitive of the
situation and the only thing without
editing that might just be of interest
you you mentioned that three of the
eight members have decided that they
would interest rate has worked with one
of those members is leaving the board
and so we're back to two names or so I
can't see that happening
imminently however are having a king for
personal reasons our interest rates over
the last few days and the two-year fixed
terms have increased in some times just
over the last whichever the last week so
in look in the long term that they
expected which is reasonable I don't
think we have any concerns interest
rates either the immediate future is to
make it thank you
talk about your thank you miss don't
come after that you were so
all the same with only two lines giving
us about other chances ones from cancer
and the others from the council's
themselves and well you can you can see
the outcome for the council you can see
how they've got there
I mean how publicly available
information you can put a seed of these
lotion requests could you give that yeah
I doubt it I am more likely a yet by
just finding a map though I was going to
be alternative investment boards by
Councillor don't think in the foredeck
Kaplan is mine
actually that's where I was going next
not by a previously happened what what I
want to just remind members is whoever
owns the cabbies are Treasury services
also the ends up it is important that
they are a company or prepared and a
financial standing we wouldn't just take
the service just because it was owned by
you know a company which we have didn't
have the most appropriate financial and
privacy natural confidence in Castle
Drive Thank You mr. chairman the two
points for length and the current
provide capital we know six thousand
pounds is v18 play ball on there now we
climb back of the attic so if you do pay
a private clinic in which link to point
to point to page six pots area second
point it mentioned as the Treasury made
on practice which was last reviewed and
updated in December with two things
existing effective for renewal and that
will be due for review at the end of
this year so similar time December time
this year okay so here assuming
but it looked at every time there's a
change in they haven't really changed
since December 5th April I believe there
will be some changes for this year and
all that comes to us again in December
and that that is more likely to be part
of the January report because we go into
the specifics on how the strategy is set
and the legislation that surrounds the
strategy so if there are any changes to
to the report as to the practices we
would report them as part of the
strategy side statement okay thank you
any other questions or comments remember
the market overall recommendation to is
emotion women research or human is there
anything like the real foundation that
it's comporting talking digital in
November remember the happy with that we
the potato point is an important way to
report for that amendment modern culture
review committees and I'm supporting
thank you you're welcome trained or not
that kind of stuff I second
moving them to attend drive another 10
to 15 business documents does anybody
need a powerful table
[Applause]
and the harder to walk longer if I take
the first laundry line a new house
service plan
I'm told that will bow on Friday in
disguise okay and then we have the sound
that exists molecular material second
which was on last month and that have
now been 31st of July and a new one on
there six to tear color of foundation
obsessions which looks a little bigger
the 31st of July for you finding the
original document that will become
intolerable and extremely period three
comments talks remember
no but first a 1-yard items involved in
anyone on the premises of Zartha the
future aspects of a and these are
evidence documents they could go in
towards a new plan is beautiful to make
sure emails are tiny to make you
involved yet
yet these are the documents that so this
little nobody able to cite this yet so
I'm not sure that the planning policy
subcommittee with those documents if we
follow will happen with the addendum to
the Shamal has been donating to discuss
it I don't anticipate there will be with
this evidence either in fact counsel a
raises an interesting question that
subcommittee never seems to meet anymore
so I don't have that confidence in
approach is something that we could
recommend the ranking subcommittee makes
delicately yeah I saw that
I'll happily supported us I'm critical
of the flag around in any meetings for
months and months and months a month
after that
because all I can see is officer to
station without any member involvement I
will maybe only but you know you're
making it for you make it cook onion I
think you have to make the
recommendations that committee the you
you feel then once you go there
pretended that yes I'm totally privates
microphones Walter I'll back it out and
so the parents the black and soul
Iranian Ally rooms perfect angle so
that's a resolution and I'll feed it
back up again
[Music]
any other questions for many members
it's not going to involve a nitrogen
work plan Linda Liam I'll be back
again on the hand over to the forest
along services remember I think what try
to do the plan now the meetings I've
spoken to the officers concerns and
populated the dates there is all all
there now lay down for when they're
going to come and say men's body
comments or questions as well as it took
many we have a sentence
any questions from members regarding
work life so it's like at the sanctuary
on in November but just like their own
your children around motion before the
review committee that is perfectly a
request for an update on an interim are
they on the building program bedroom the
home I haven't actually requested them
to come yet but I will go because maybe
they've outstanding sending things to do
this yeah yes yes surely turn interest
and the missus actually
not because I think it's believed the
opportunity actually will that make soil
to build a sanctuary themselves without
a maintenance anchoring up through the
Rockford committee okay so those whose
ability times 360 just work with it like
I just don't want to this thing not to
be declaring interpreter should be
because of sensitivity the country's
situation captain madam for some
concerns regarding factory housing and
communal house and running they're being
raised by federal council James Newport
to chief executive as an ongoing emails
customer will those issues be addressed
by social anything I know you know that
it's scheduled just to be they came last
night them at all and went through their
house building program and this is it
would be an update on that rather than
any separate issue last this follows to
have interest based on recent events to
know in London in terms of building
materials used by century housing and
stuff we are discussing those motives
that wouldn't be or isn't scheduled in
another make
Kevin we've got a point on this report
they said additional work options to be
completed program the right site without
what we're discussing now you cannot
confuse the microphones having United
sort of Factory have something of I was
writing an issue see that's always being
discussed at our meetings this must've
done numbers of proxy you know he
remember the the councillors entered
into an agreement with it's actually a
legal agreement which defines a certain
number of houses to be delivered by
March 2018 early started on our 2018
this committee has looked at that issue
and firefall councils required the chief
executive to complete the negotiation
which is part of that so legal agreement
they are the intention of this November
meeting this November before is to
understand what has happened since the
last time you can be sorted the
expectation is that for council will
receive will have received a report from
the chief executives detailing how that
number against be delivered in in ten
years and types of building but if they
haven't then of course we have the
opportunity in November to you know to
cross that bridge and all the way but
more particularly to get a report on the
progress because if they have to start
them by March 18 you think by November
they know what they're going to do
putting it absolutely you know in
definitive terms so that's what that's
all about really thank you
just one minute there's an opportunity
to bring back their nature and claim I'm
going to anyone for been following once
again specifically with regards to these
aliens rear 10 that is you're quite the
golfer that being here when we had
presentation before for counsel very low
promise to continue engagement with the
council suppose we do have the
opportunity to clear a either for a
reviewing or whether leg and combats for
counsel but the element our fully
support which adds of giving keep you
and I on this I just think it should
come back to council I thought the
chance of meeting know very well and I
think I think we should tell people
event while Andrea to revisions you can
I very especially the German did they
not say yet the NHS people that they've
known a going for public consultation
September October time in temporary
service remember was it so should we
have them back after public college
personal patient but that's what it what
needs to be agree with that so you
committee or for counsel calculation
those two perspectives on the
consultation there we are individual
residents and we had the right to
participate in that consultation like
like any other but at the same time had
the council having expressed an interest
to received report from the successor
examine elders I would expect that the
council would want to respond to the
consultation in its own right in which
case
I kind of follow up on where counselor
black is to say that I would want that
to have the strength or full counsel
behind it great like s an amazing on
pencil in it that it would be a lot of
people better for counter welder than
really think I'm beautiful
okay the was one issue with review in
the medical practitioners who couldn't
speak of full counsel other than the one
that the NHS particularly put at the end
which is for against sorting out review
could present their evidence okay if
that was done harder the full calm not
sure all the things other what we like
or we here yeah um I'm under dr.
Caroline held lives in my water so he
lives next on remember the council which
is a great interest it is understood by
me that and dr. Howard wouldn't be able
to just turn up to any presentations of
the council but she will and can it was
invited by council so even a for council
before council were to invite her then
she'd be able to attend the only reason
she was actually invited because we
insisted on having us attempt because it
was going to be just as this injury
presented and so it was on our
insistence that she came to give a
balanced cable which obviously would
have had to happen again that you have
to be invited the council not
permit me to bite a soda can it sounds
to me as if from the communities discuss
something will come up with me the
recommendations of all council and I
don't see any reason why that shouldn't
it be formalized in it to ensure that we
have considered the matter as part of
our work plan would be further over the
right improper reasons in full council
in into two situations one before or
during the consultation to receive and
updates on success regime and dr. Howard
and others who would apply but also post
the consultation what the expectations
of the public are in being response to
it well so if we could lot of Linda
still run up yes agree just wanted it
highlight that in your notice from the
home that said already there the January
doesn't have any beautiful and now and
select members know there is a press
release is being issued by the council
is directly inviting members of public
subject areas for view I believe it go
now either later this week or early next
week something for now again what we are
able to discuss additional item that can
be added to the work plan and if anyone
wants to because that's not been feel
free but it likes the idea to keep
generally free for now just because of
our suggestions made by members of the
pocket and or more than one topic may
even take place exactly that but the
realization that what we discussed or
railing additional items tonight
everything for education at Catherines
man I would generally don't remember
council only by raising it so but I I'm
becoming aware of all sorts and claims
of all difficulties with maintenance and
costs upon the rate of the tenants of
sanctuary and following up on what
councilor mountain had to say if that's
another one I'm thinking it's a separate
subject and I think it would be
appropriate to invite in your sanctuary
and to discuss particular issues and
that ability built up by five residents
and tenants makes it easier if we do it
in the review committee then to leave it
to individual board members scattered
across the district in order to take on
tapings things on themselves and maybe
we can form of you across the district
as opposed to individuals
just after you will not it would be
appropriate of embossing dream two
separate occasions and whether or not we
could Robin why it was determined any
amount of significance and penetrate and
the housing stock that they ran already
have their resident so it's not
unreasonable to have to attain twice as
long and in fact about don't think it's
unreasonably second two times three
times while we've got problems and
outstanding issues then we need to be
able to express those children and get
some feedback I have heard of some of
the concerns other war councils of God I
think it would be helpful practice that
inflation is collectively perhaps given
to an proprietor lately so that they had
a chance as well to rethink that but
it's concerning that our residents who
have these issues and they appear to be
following from what I've heard of
long-standing and they're just that we
do it intersects me an odd bit of
dependent on same treatment Lincoln's
Deline discussion to what me to the
views on that cancer Lucas kids till
three months ago counselor sure heart
for making the century on this subject
and if I remember rightly call the RT
day fact was that we couldn't ask for
best items until King junior
generalities but not specific how tops
to such confusion so you know about
those clear vision talks about buildings
and things like that but you know we
talked jointly hampton to one residence
issue the communities of some of you are
so common I know from my wife studies of
problems she had
not on the problems were similar effect
on various other residents it would give
the block of not the address or you
could say it's a fire exit which of
course is communal if it's something to
do with Windows or cookers if you've got
ten in substances you don't actually
have to say the specific address you can
say in this block there are issues I
don't really feel that they need to be
taken to des consommateurs yes
so it comes along in church and perhaps
a calculation saying it's not for
individual members to take up issues so
that I think is exactly that in the
first instance and that was my
understanding of the arrangement that we
have that would counselors should be
involved in the first instance and where
there are common issues or master issues
in the same spaces or multiple attempts
to resolve something then becomes an
issue that is refer either to one of the
committee members to take to the
community or for collectively on solid
councils really cell channel or other
but to actually not address any of those
issues fed through the board member is
not the right route with my
understanding Thank You Chancellor
Madame thanks Jerry following on to
learn or cancel only say there are
issues that have been attended to by
water members in our very wars such as
the properties sanctuary are responsible
for in March away and signal hands and
there are specific
residents raising repeated issues but I
would say they cover the topics of
maintenance and cleanliness and and we I
think it's absolutely fair and this
forward to ask these general questions
to get reassurances from sanctuary so we
can then report
to our aliens within our ward that this
is the Corson actions being taken place
because of the moment we've got
situations where that they're not
answering questions they're in retreat
so at least we can as cancel on the said
we can as war counselors communicate to
our residents directly that they need to
see it as residents that some actions
there takes place so I actually take
advantage of making Thank You councillor
Cooper thank you sir I don't think I've
got enough time in a day to see all my
residents the complaints on the
maintenance side of the sanctuary and
just over the last couple of weeks I
must have a at least a dozen people
contact me and this is where I feel that
exactly should come in and we should put
it in a block so that we can all
question one you know what's happening
on the maintainer side of it and why are
you using it seems to me substandard
workmanship to repair these places I
mean if you want photographic evidence
of the work that's been carried out you
know I can bring some happiness so much
of it and you know we can ask same tree
as abroad you know what is actually
happening on the maintenance side of
things and then we can take it back to
the residence and say world blah blah
blah and what's going to go on from
there if you can suspend yes thank you
firm they don't so it's not only the
material things that are going wrong
that we understand it's also that there
when you bring people from residents of
sanctuary that they help lower these
awake engaged and they don't seem to be
getting help any help whatsoever
and they don't see and on the prompts
that they made that counts for counsel
they would speak to the residents or
individual residents to find out exactly
what's wrong and I've heard
the different things going on that
they're not be interested and the
helpline is always currently guys I
think there's another thing that we need
to work address thank you thank you hey
Thank You Man
well I was going to say it's that in
order to know what's common perhaps we
should look at common headings and have
a troll of issues and then oven issues
of some views being really hammered over
a turbine and has been flogged off for
about four years have now been presented
with a very big bill as well because of
maintenance to the block OSHA cause
outrage and waiting to hear what happens
about that one first engineering term
that I like cleanliness maintenance and
so on so we've got some idea of what to
approach it with you know that way we're
not going to focus on an individual's
property or whatever but basically cover
those issues
another nice fair because it's our
housing stock and it's also the
development of our housing stock it's
quite crucial area all the pivoting
Council along thank you change I think
and just to inform this committee about
as portfolio Hospital last year there
was a time when I was about to have that
discussion around the council voted
others that are housed in factory
accommodation around the repair
dimension that's personal illness
expense or otherwise of that decided in
conversation we shall have gotten at the
time but that was not the right time to
do that but it could be that that is
another deal we should now be going down
which is for the portfolio holder
responsibility to be actually looking at
that position given what we're hearing
around the table thank you Miss amazing
Janet I am I think the council earning
points about issues being raised in both
counselors and in some instances there
there is urgency I must admit I didn't
foresee us wait until January 2 to deal
with this so I had in in mind that you
would be cooling our relatives in Ward
reports under the headings that
councilman suggests and and having a
much earlier meeting with with sanctuary
and I don't favor going through the full
very home alone because I think there's
much wider issues to be considered
materials is one we don't know the
answer to that and I don't think it
should be just simply either warden and
is taking the stash older along this or
indeed the portfolio which is why we
have a review committee it hasn't
happened and I'd like to see it happen
much much earlier than than January
although then the I policy was happening
again it's at all possible chairman and
in September or even earlier it and the
program important we couldn't could
actually meet in order to do the math
educate and yet is backing up what
counsel is making this occur again I
don't see this would be suitable for the
portfolio holder to take on equal to
Omega it's through those two two minutes
individual class was to respond to the
in the day in terms of asking sanctuary
to come in the concerns that you know
should we be asking is coming we're
talking about sanctuary being
responsible for our vulnerable residents
on many occasions and I think is
absolutely right that we should be
scrutinizing them as often as we see fit
until these issues are resolved any
other comment
okay remember that monster normally
suggest a review of some tree house in
general maximum proposed are happy model
Olivia now there's a whole load of
people wanting to do that I think nearly
everyone around the table yo not just me
it's not just them I think we need to do
a bit of a bit of work behind the rear
situation to find out from our offices
and then folio a hold of the excessively
individual complaint the law we made to
the council and then mob up from board
members what other ones are happening
and in general have a conversation
around the district to ferret them all
now so we get to a pretty consolidated
position as there as we can cancel quite
complete Germantown
which is really is a suggestion that
whether this committee is happy to have
an additional meeting in August if it is
that if that's been a most appropriate
time to do it yep I think thank you
we'll finally all right so you've got
this possible
I mean my first four columns the EXPEED
space sanctuary see what
and they can fit something in an August
or whether they want to go to September
they went out September ailment the
allymeier themselves won't be the are
they obviously too soon in order to
collect information I think members on
the one I think this probably locked
members are pumping theater in August so
I'll I'll go around and try and sort the
town and artist amend the work plan
accordingly so hopefully I still read
that bacteria yeah but there's as normal
hours in RL like tense all members are
happy and comfortable with that so
hands-on with measurement questions or
prints folks on campus planning a lot
effectively I don't have to worry about
a little bit about sanctuary as they are
their own bosses right and you can do so
how by flames how they want to run their
business coming from what have you so in
a lot of cases and I think is going to
find it that their argument thinking are
trying to do their best
as well as what we are doing at this
present time and I just wonder just how
much influence we have to towards and
you know we we can't dictate to them
what we what we want but we can ask them
those questions lot for our residents
that are in their housing
howdy sort of accommodation but maybe
influence communities accountability if
the main all topic
I do understand your comments here
central conservatism can be followed
balanced here what should mr. chairman I
think that there's one thing that we're
forgetting that there are unraveling is
open to that is if there are issues that
in the optioning result we've got health
and safety we've got fire offices there
is something we can do and so we should
not be doing is ignoring it and every
one that might hurdle French sanctuary
it would appear to be a long term
repeated problem now that's probably not
true that probably only ones from about
so many easy ones development but we
should be looking at sometimes we can
ask for members to provide this than
photographic evidence and then see what
situation but I think they ought to
prejudge it but we do need to deal with
it class of people home once mentioned
in disaster so both objects that the
idea of rats and presenting the
questions in advance to sanctuary sorts
we've collected how we want to approach
it and they they will know so we've been
also trying to we want what's best for
our residents really model we we've to
answer if we could serve in questions
results I'd love the currents coming I
think the the other thing Chairman's of
course we heard that that I think we the
the sanctuary spend forty million pounds
on on maintenance in this in this
district I can't remember what fear is
but it sounded like a really impressive
bunch of money that suggests to me
they've got a rolling program in which
cases we need that to be elucidated and
presented to us because it could be
there are some things in there but you
know create a an overall picture rather
than the individual sports capital on
occasion
just stay 40 million I believe was the
planned program all the research that
agreed in the dancer it's not the
ongoing maintenance of the color stock
with the updating and upgrading over ten
years and that's what they're currently
completely and 17 stripes on can play
with roof swing it sound relevant yeah
can't open even this little bit of them
worked on an awakened at the moment so
ought to be completed by March 18 so
start to get some feedback from people
up there there are their dues on the
works being going so some of that that's
going to feeding potentially include
into this for this particular topic when
we bring to its or not its current and
running and having them it's a lot the
positive hope that it is if I as we just
add to that that the six Shelton schemes
that what all five because we won't talk
about the one that's changed its purpose
but those are all due to be released in
some ways in the next six multiple
family so that'll be the ten-year
program of almost all covered
but I think of it inhalation